David Boder: [In English] Wiesbaden, September the 25th, 1946, in the community house of a Jewish community maintained by UNRRA but billeted in German homes. The interviewee is Mr. Joseph from Poland, who prefers not to give his full name.
David Boder: [In German]...Also Herr Joseph, kommen Sie mal näher hier.
Joseph [last name unknown]: Ja.
David Boder: Und wollen Sie mir sagen...er kann Yiddisch reden, was wär besser?
David Boder: [In Yiddish] װילסטו מיר זאגן, װאו זײד איר געײעזן, װען די מלחמה האט זיך אנגעפאנגן אר...די לעצטיקע [אומהערבאר] װען עס האט אנגעפאנגן צו פאסירן פארשידענע באגעבנהײטן, װאס האט מאל ראוסגעבראכט מענשן פאן נארמאלן לעבן.
Joseph [last name unknown]: פארן קריג איף געװױנט אין פױלן
David Boder: [In German] Welche Stadt
Joseph [last name unknown]: [In Yiddish] אין קריניצא, קורארט...אין נײן און דרייסיקסטן יאר בין איך מאביליזירט געווארן צום מיליטער
David Boder: ווי אלט זענט איר יעצט?
Joseph [last name unknown]: פינף און פערציק יאר.
David Boder: זענט איר געוועזן א סאלדאט בעפאר?
Joseph [last name unknown]: יא. געוועזן א סאלדאט ביי עסטרייך...און ביי פוילן ביי אכצן יאר אוף.
David Boder: זענט איר געווארן מאביליזירט?
Joseph [last name unknown]: נאך מאביליזירט געװארן. צוליב מיין קראנקהייט, האט מען מיך אנטשלאסן אויף דריי חדשים אורלויב.
David Boder: ווי גרויס איז אײרע פאמיליע געווען?
David Boder: [In German]...Also, ich will, dass Sie mir alles sagen. Sie brauchen mir die Namen nicht zu geben. Also hat Sie noch genummen in die polnische Armee [unverständlich]
Joseph [last name unknown]: [In Yiddish] יא, צוליב מיין קראנקהייט
David Boder: אבער איך האב אייך שוין געפרעגט, ווי גרויס איז איירע פאמיליע געווען?
Joseph [last name unknown]: מיין פאמיליע האט באשטאנען מאן און פרוי.
David Boder: קיינע קינדער?
Joseph [last name unknown]: קיינע קינדער. יא.
David Boder: און צוליב איירע קראנקהייט, וואס איז איירע קראנקהייט?
Joseph [last name unknown]: מיין קראנקהייט איז געקומען אויף די נירן. גענצליך [אומהערבאר] די נירן. האט מען מיך אנטשלאסן אויף דריי חדשים. איך האב געוואלט אהיימ פורן צו מיין פאמיליע. די פראנט איז שוין געווען פאררופן, בין איך געגאנגן קיין דראהאביטש.
David Boder: וועלכע פראנט?
Joseph [last name unknown]: דער פראנט דייטשלאנד אויף פוילן. מען איז געגאנגן קיין דראהאביטש צו פיס און מען איז געקומען קיין דראהאביטש.
David Boder: מיט איירע ווייב?
Joseph [last name unknown]: מיין ווייב האט נישט געקענט מער קימען, ווייל די פראנט איז פארריסן געווארן [אומהערבאר].
David Boder: זענט איר געווארן מאביליזירט?
Joseph [last name unknown]: נאך מאביליזירט געװארן. צוליב מיין קראנקהייט, האט מען מיך אנטשלאסן אויף דריי חדשים אורלויב.
David Boder: ווי גרויס איז אײרע פאמיליע געווען?
David Boder: [In German]...Also, ich will, dass Sie mir alles sagen. Sie brauchen mir die Namen nicht zu geben. Also hat Sie noch genummen in die polnische Armee [unverständlich]
Joseph [last name unknown]: [In Yiddish] יא, צוליב מיין קראנקהייט
David Boder: אבער איך האב אייך שוין געפרעגט, ווי גרויס איז איירע פאמיליע געווען?
Joseph [last name unknown]: מיין פאמיליע האט באשטאנען מאן און פרוי.
David Boder: קיינע קינדער?
Joseph [last name unknown]: קיינע קינדער. יא.
David Boder: און צוליב איירע קראנקהייט, וואס איז איירע קראנקהייט?
Joseph [last name unknown]: מיין קראנקהייט איז געקומען אויף די נירן. גענצליך [אומהערבאר] די נירן. האט מען מיך אנטשלאסן אויף דריי חדשים. איך האב געוואלט אהיימ פורן צו מיין פאמיליע. די פראנט איז שוין געווען פאררופן, בין איך געגאנגן קיין דראהאביטש.
David Boder: וועלכע פראנט?
Joseph [last name unknown]: דער פראנט דייטשלאנד אויף פוילן. מען איז געגאנגן קיין דראהאביטש צו פיס און מען איז געקומען קיין דראהאביטש.
David Boder: מיט איירע ווייב?
Joseph [last name unknown]: מיין ווייב האט נישט געקענט מער קומען ווייל די פראנט איז שוין פאררופן געווארן האט זי צו מיר מער נישט געקענט קימען. מען איז געקומען קיין דראהאביטש. בין איך געווען אין דראהאביטש צוויי טוג. זענען אריינגעקומען די דייטשן און האבן מיך געפאקט אין דראהאביטש. דארט האב איך געזען אז עס איז שוין נישטא וואס צו מאכן, האב איך מיך געלאזט אויפן וועג צוריק אהיים קיין קרעניץ. בין איך געגאנגן דורך פשעמישל. איך בין געקומען פאר פשעמישל, צוויי קילאמעטער פאר פשעמישל געוועזן א באמבע מיטן די גאס, אויסגעריסן א גרויסע לאך. זענען מיר אדורכגעגאנגן אכצן יידן. האבן די דייטשן אונז אראפגענומען און מען האט געהייסן אויסגראבן גריבער פאר זיךפאר צװײ מעטכר לאנג און מיט די ערד באשיטן די ערד וואס מען פון דעם, פון די באמבע.
David Boder: יא.
Joseph [last name unknown]: אויסגעריסן. א יעדע שאוועל וואס מיר האבן ארויסגעגראבן ערד האבן מיר אריינגעכאפט קלעפ. עס האט שטארק גערעגנט דעמאלטס, האבן מיר געוואלט אויסטון זיך די מענטל וואס מיר זענען געגאנגן האט מען נישט געלאזט נאר צוזאמען מיט די מענטלעך אין די גרעסטע בלאטעס האט מען אונז געצווינגן דאס דארפסט טון. מיר האבן אזוי געארבעט דריי שעה. זייגער אכט ביינאכט, עס איז שוין געווען גוט פינסטער, זאגט דער קאמאנדיר, דער לײטענאנט, [אומהערבאר]. קאמאנדא, איינס, צוויי, דריי. [אומהערבאר] דירעקציאן לעמבערג. מיר האבן נישט געוואוסט, װאס [אומהערבאר] נאך פשעצישל און דירעקציאן לעמבערג װאר צוריק נאך [אומהערבאר] נאך פשעמישל געגאנגען [אומהערבאר] אנגעפאנגן צו שיסן [אומהערבאר] האבן מיר זיך געלייגט אויף די ערד [אומהערבאר], בעט האט קיינעם נישט געטראפן מיר גײן קײן פשעמישל, די אלע אכצן ײדן. מיר קימען אריין קיין פשעמישל. האלט! שטאנדרעכט! [אומהערבאר] מיר האבן נישט געוואוסט. און מיר האבן געבעטן אז מען זאל אונז לאזן ווייל מיר זענען ערשט אוועקגעגאנגן פון די ארבעט, האט מען אונז געלאזט. האט אונז אהיימגענומען צו זיך א ייד וואס האט געהאט ביי די באן א רעסטוראנ, שלוסן. האט ער געקלאפט ביים טויער. קימט ארויס דארט א פרוי, זאגט זי, “וואס זענט איר געקימען, דערבארעמט אייך, מען האט היינט אויס’גע’הרג’ט זעקס הינדערט און פופציק ײדן, און איר זענט געקימען אין גרעסטן פייער אריין.” וואו, האבן מיר געפרעגט? ווער ווייסט אז מען האט גע’הרג’ט יידן? ווער, וואספארא ײדן? מען האט גענומען אלע ביידע רבנים, אלע אדוואקאטן, מיט די טעכטער און מיט די זין און מיט די קינדער און מען האט זיי גע’הרג’ט. נא, לאזט אונז אריין. האט מען אונז אריינגעלאזט. און מיר האבן די גאנצע נאכט געשלאפן אויפן בוידעם, באהאלטן און אינ דער פרי קימט צוגיין צוויי מאן פון די געסטאפא און פרעגט זיך ווי זענען די לױטע וואס זענען געסטערן אבענד געקאמען. שטייגט די פרוי אינדרויסן [אומהערבאר], “זאגן זי נישט קיין ליגן?” זאגט זי, ניין. נא, קיינער ווייסט נישט. זענען מיר געליגן אזוי ביז ערב יום כיפור. ערב יום כיפור זענען מיר געגאנגן דאווענען אין א שיל, דארטן האבן מיר געדאווענט, און צומארגענס, צומארגענס איז געקומען א באפעל אז די גאנצע גאס זאל אויס-עוואקיוירט.
David Boder: װאו?
Joseph [last name unknown]: אין א גארנישט. קיין שום מעשיות. ארויס אין די גאס. די גאס איז געוועזן ביי די שיל. א טעמפל און ביי די שיל.
David Boder: די קריסטן און די ײדן זאל מען געדארפט אוועקיוירן?
Joseph [last name unknown]: ניין, נאר די ײדן. נאר די ײדן. אבער מיר האבן מורא געהאט ארויסצוגיין און מיר זענען נישט ארויס און מיר זענען ווייטער געבליבן. ערב סוכות, דריי אזייגער פארטאגס שטייען די ײדן ביי די בעקיארד [אומהערבאר] געשטאנען ביים פארקויפן, האב איך געזען דורכן פענסטער פון דריטן שטאק, אהין אראפגעקוקט, ווי מען האט גענומען בענזין און אנגעהויבן צו גיסן אויף די שוהל און באלד אנגעצינדן, האט א ווייבל געמאכט א געוואלד, ” ײדן הייבט’ס אייך אויף, ס’ ברענט.” האט ער ארויסגענומען א רעוואלווער אין געשאסן. האט מען אינטערגעצינדן דעם טעמפל, דאס איז געווען די ערשטע.
David Boder: א שוהל און א טעמפל?
Joseph [last name unknown]: א שוהל און א טעמפל.
David Boder: וואס איז דער חילוק?
Joseph [last name unknown]: א טעמפל דאס איז א מאדערנער. א שוהל איז מער ארטאדאקסיש. אויפ’ן זייגער, דריי שעה שפעטער האבן אלע דרײ שילן געברענט.
David Boder: וואס איז די דריטע?
Joseph [last name unknown]: די דריטע שיל איז געווען א חסידיש בית המדרש. האבן אלע דריי שוהלן געברענט, און מען האט געגעבן א באפעל אז מען מוז ארויס אין די גאסן דארט. האט מען זיך צוזאמען גענומען, אלע וויפיל מען האט געקענט, קליינע קינדער און מען איז אנטלאפן אונטער די שטאט. און א גאנצע טאג האט געברענט, געברענט, געברענט ביז צוועלעף אזייגער ביינאכט. ערב סוכות ביינאכט, צוועלעף זייגער איז שטיל אריינגעקומען און אזייגער פיר אינדערפרי איז אריינגעקומען די רויטער ארמיי. איז אריינגעקומען די רויטע ארמיי און זיי האבן דורכגעטיילט פשעמישל. האלב פשעמישל איז געוועזן רויט, די רויטע ארמיי. און די אנדערע האלב פשעמישל איז געוועזן [אומהערבאר].
David Boder: די רוסן האבן זיך נאכ נישט געקריגט מיט די דייטשן דענמאלס?
Joseph [last name unknown]: ניין, ניין דענמאלס איז מען נאך געווען גיטע ברידער.אזוי זענען מיר געבליבן אין פשעמישל אונטער די רוסן און איך האב אין פשעמישל אנגעהויבן צו ארבעטן און איך האב אהיימגעשריבן מיין ווייב אז זי זאל מיר שרייבן וואס מען הערט אינ דער היים, האט מיין ווייב געשריבן, אז זי וויל קימען צו מיר. האב איך איר געשריבן אז זי זאל קימען. זי איז צוגעקימען קיין סאנאק, צים [אומהערבאר], האבן איר די דייטשן נישט אדורכגעלאזט אויפן וואסער. זיי האבן איר נאך געזאגט אז זי זאל אריינגיין אין וואסער און אזוי ווי זי האט נישט געקענט אריינגיין אין וואסער אזוי ווי זי האט געהאט א סך פאקעטן האט זי געווארט ביז זי וועט האבן די מעגליכקייט אריבערצוגיין די טריקענע גרעניץ. אזוי האט זי דארט געווארט צוויי וואכן און מען האט איר נישט אדורכגעלאזט, זי איז צוריק אהיים, און ביז’ן היינטיגן טאג האב איך איר מער נישט געזען. זי איז אומגעקומען. אין גריבוב האט מען זי געשאסן.
David Boder: ווער האט אייך דאס איבערגעזאגט?
Joseph [last name unknown]: די וואס זענען געווען צוזאמען אין אוישוויץ, אין לאגער האבן דאס געזען. געוואר געווארן.
David Boder: איר זענט דאך נישט געווען אין אוישוויץ?
Joseph [last name unknown]: איך בין נישט געווען אין אוישוויץ, ניין.
David Boder: [אומהערבאר]
Joseph [last name unknown]: אומהערבאר] זי איז צוזאמען געווען מיט זיי. זיי האבן זיך געראטעוועט, די מענטשן און זיי האט מען געשאסן. מען האט געשאסן אזוי. דאס ווייב, ברידער, מיינס א ברידער און מיינס א שוואוגער, נאך צוויי שוואוגערס. דריי שוואגערס האט מען געשאסן. איין שוואוגער האט געהאט זעקס קינדער, איינער האט געהאט פיר קינדער און איינער האט געהאט פינף קינדער. און נאך שוואוגערס, זיי זענען געווען פון גריביץ. די ווייס איך אויך נישט ווי זיי זענען אהינגעקומען. מיר האבן געארבעט אין פשעמישל, האבן מיר אזוי דורכגעארבעט ביזן מאנאט מאי. מאי האט זיך אנגעהויבן מאכן א נייע גלות. די רוסן האבן אנגעהויבן קומען ביינאכט און שטוב אריין און מען האט אנגעהויבן ארויסצונעמען מענטשן. מען האט נישט געוואוסט וואו אהין, וואוס. א טוג שפעטער איז ארויסגעהאנגן א צעטל אז עס איז א רעגיסטרירונג וואו אהין מען וויל, צו מען וויל אהיים צים דייטש, צו מען וויל ארויסנעמען א פאשפארט. האבן זיך א סך מענטשן רעגיסטרירט, זיי ווילן ארויסנעמען פאשפארטן און א סך מענטשן האבן זיך רעגיסטרירט אז זיי ווילן צוריק אהיים. און די מענטשן וואס האבן זיך רעגיסטרירט אז זיי ווילן אהיים, האט מען זיי גענומען און אוועקגעשיקט מיטן טראנספארט קיין רוסלאנד.
David Boder: קיין רוסלאנד?
Joseph [last name unknown]: יא.
David Boder: זיי האבן דאך געדארפט צו ווילן גיין אהיים צום דייטש?
Joseph [last name unknown]: יא. האט מען געשיקט קיין רוסלאנד. די וואס האבן געזאגט זיי ווילן אהיים גיין קיין, קיין, צום דייטש, אהיים! נישט צום דייטש, אהיים צום ווייב.
David Boder: אבער די דייטש איז דאך דארט געווען?
Joseph [last name unknown]: יא, אבער איך בין דאך נישט געגאנגן אהיים צום דייטש. מען איז אהיים צום ווייב, צו די מאמע, צו די ברידער, האט מען געשיקט קיין רוסלאנד.
David Boder: איר האט דאן פארשריבן אויך צו גיין אהיים?
Joseph [last name unknown]: יא. ווייל דאס ווייב האט דאך נישט געקענט אריבערפארן.
David Boder: האט מען אייך פארשיקט קיין רוסלאנד?
Joseph [last name unknown]: האט מען געשיקט קיין רוסלאנד. אויפן וועג מיטן טראנספארט, קיין רוסלאנד, האט מען אזוי געטון מיט אונז: די וואס האבן געהאט ווייבער מיט קינדער, די האט מען געשיקט צוזאמען, צוזאמען און די וואס זענען געווען אליין, אזוי ווי איך בין געווען אליין אן ווייב, האט מען אראפגענומען און מען האט זיי איינגעשפארט [אומהערבאר] און מען האט מיר געהאלטן פיר וואכן אין די טורמע און געמאכט יעדן טאג פראטאקאלן, פראטאקאלן, וואס מען איז געווען און ווען מען איז געוועזן. און נאך די פראטאקאלן האט מען אונז פארשיקט קיין רוסלאנד און מען האט באקומען אזוי, צו דריי יאר, צו פינעף יאר, צו אכט יאר, צו צען יאר. מיר זענען געווען אין לאגער
David Boder: מען האט געמשפ’ט?
Joseph [last name unknown]: מען האט גע’משפ’ט.
David Boder: פארוואס?
Joseph [last name unknown]: פארוואס ווייסט קיינער נישט. מען האט אפגעשריבן א נאכט א פראטאקאל און מען האט געמוזט זאגן אזוי ווי זיי האבן געוואלט, און מען האט באקומען צו אכט און צו צען און צו דריי און צו פינף יאר. שוין.
David Boder: [אומהערבאר]
Joseph [last name unknown]: [אומהערבאר] טארנאפאל אין די טיורמע האט מען באקומען. דארט האט מען אוועקגעשיקט אין לאגער אױף סוכע בעזװאדנע. נאך אנדערע לאגערס. סיביר.
David Boder: פארוואס האט מען אייך אוועקגעשיקט?
Joseph [last name unknown]: א סוכע בעזװאדנע.
David Boder: [אומהערבאר]
Joseph [last name unknown]: יא. סוכע בעזװאדנע. דארטן זענען מיר געוועזן אין לאגער. געארבעט שווער. און מען האט געפינען א סך מענטשן זענען געשטארבן פאר הינגער. און מען האט נישט געקענט אויסהאלטן, די קעלט איז געווען זייער גרויס.
David Boder: וואו איז עס די שטאט וואו מען האט אייך געשיקט? וואו איז עס?
Joseph [last name unknown]: דאס איז ביי װאלגע. דאס איז דריי הונדערט קילאמעטער פון דארטן.
David Boder: וואס האט איר דארטן געארבעט?
Joseph [last name unknown]: אין וואלד.
Joseph [last name unknown]: געארבעט האב איך אין וואלד. ביי האלץ געשניטן. געהאקט ביימער. אז א סך פון אונזערע ברידערס זענען, אז א בוים איז אומגעפאלן שלעכט וואס [אומהערבאר] זענען זיי גע’הרג’ט געווארן פון בוים.
David Boder: ווער האט עס ארגאנאזירט די ארבעט? ווער האט די [אומהערבאר] געײאכט?
Joseph [last name unknown]: די וואך איז געוועזן אינדרויסן.
David Boder: יא?
Joseph [last name unknown]: די רוסן זענען געווען די וואך.
David Boder: פון ווי האט מען געלעבט? וואס האט מען געגעסן?
Joseph [last name unknown]: געגעסן האט מען, מען האט באקימען זעקס הונדערט גראם ברויט א טוג. אויב איינער איז געווען א גיטער ארבײטער, ער האט געהאט א סך כח מער צו מאכן די [אומהערבאר] האט ער געהאט א רעכט צוצוקויפן זיך נאך דריי הונדערט גראם ברויט.
David Boder: קויפן. האט מען געצאלט פאר די ארבעט?
Joseph [last name unknown]: פאר די ארבעט? האט מען, יא. מען האט באקומען. גאנץ ווייניג געצאלט. אבער מען האט באקומען עפעס. די וואס האבן אויסגעפירט [אומהערבאר] איז געווען זייער שווער ארויסצופארן ווייל עס איז געווען זייער גרויסע [אומהערבאר] און עס איז געווען גרויסע קעלט ווינטער, ביי די אכט און פערציק גראד פראסט. און מען איז נישט געווען אזוי צוגעוואוינט צו דעם קלימאט, זייער א שווערע קלימאט. עס איז געווען זייער קאלט, און די ווינטער געדויערט זייער לאנג. ארום 7-8 חדשים דויערט די ווינטער.
David Boder: וואס פאר א קליידער האט מען געטראגן?
Joseph [last name unknown]: מען האט געטראגן, די קליידער זענען געוועזן [אומהערבאר] קליידער, [אומהערבאר].
David Boder: וואס פארא שיך?
Joseph [last name unknown]: שיך איז געוועזן. עס האט דענמאלס אויסגעפעלט. א סך האבן נאך געהאט װאליענקי [אומהערבאר] און פאר א סך האט שוין אויסגעפעלט האט מען באקימען שיך. אויף די שיך האט מען אנגעטון אזעלכע [אומהערבאר] אלעס איינס האט דאס אדורגענעצט, אז עס איז געווען שרעקליכע שנייען, זייער א סך.
David Boder: און וואס האט מען געמאכט פון די האלץ? וואס פאר א האלץ האט מען עס געשניטן?
Joseph [last name unknown]: דאס האלץ האט מען געשניטן, הויכע ביימער וואס מען האט דאס געשניטן, [אומהערבאר] צוויי מעטערדיקע, מעטערדיקע צו מעטער, מעטערדיקע צו פיר מעטער, עס איז געווען א האלבע מעטער אויך און דאס איז צוגעקימען, אין לאגער אריין אין וואלד איז צוגעקימען די באן און האט דאס האלץ ארויסגעפירט.
Joseph [last name unknown]: נאר מיר, איך בין נישט צוגעוואוינט געוועזן צי די קאסט אויך ווייל עס איז געוועזן, מען האט געהאט ווייניק, דאס עסן איז געווען זייער ווייניק אזוי אז איך האב באקימען געשוואלענע פיס, די דאקטער האט געזוגט אז איך דארף צי האבן בעסערע עסן. נאכדעם זענען מיר די הענט געשוואלן געווארן און איך האב באקומען אזעלכע אבסעסן אויפן גאנצן לייבן. נאך זעקס מאנאטן איז אראפגעקימען א קאמיסיע פון מאסקווע און האט געזען, אנגעקיקט דעם גאנצן לאגער, האבן און איינגעטיילט דעם לאגער אין דריי לאגערס. גאר געזונטע האט מען געשיקטע אין א דריי און צוואנציגסטן לאגער. מיטל – אזעלכע וואס דארפן זיך אויסריען האט מען געשיקט אויף דריי וואכן אויסרוען קיין א צווייטן לאגער, און א פופצענטן לאגער און גאר שוואכע האט מען געשיקט אין ניינטן לאגער. דארט איז געווען די ארבעט שוואכער און מען האט די מענטשן שוין נישט געצווינגן צי די ארבעט. עס איז געווען א שוואכע לאגער. דארטן,
David Boder: וואו האט מען אייך געשיקט?
Joseph [last name unknown]: מיר האט מען געשיקט אין ניינטן לאגער.
David Boder: פאר די שוואכע?
Joseph [last name unknown]: דארט איז די שוואכע. יא. דארט האב איך געארבעט שוין א שוואכערע ארבעט. דארט האב איך געארבעט ביז צים באפרייאונג. ביז עס איז ארויסגעקימען די באפרייאונג.
David Boder: ווארט. וואס איז געקומען פון אייערע געשווירן פון אייערע קראנקהייטן. האט זיך עס אויסגעהיילט?
Joseph [last name unknown]: אין דעם ניינטן לאגער האט מען געגעבן אזעלכע לעקארסטװא, דאס הייסט מען האט געגעבן מעדיצינען צו דעם. מען האט געגעבן הייבן צו טרינקן. מען האט געגעבן קארטאפל, צוויבל.
David Boder: וואס האט מען געגעבן צו טרינקן?
Joseph [last name unknown]: הייפן, הייפן
David Boder: העפן
Joseph [last name unknown]: יא.
David Boder: דראזשדזשי.
Joseph [last name unknown]: דראזשדזשי. יא. יא. דארט איז שוין נישט געווען אזוי געפערלעך, מען האט געקענט אויסהאלטן. מען איז נישט אזוי פרי געגאנגן צי דער ארבעט.
David Boder: זענען עס געווען נאר יידן אין דעם לאגער אדער אלע?
Joseph [last name unknown]: דארטן געוועזן א זיבעציק פראצענט יידן און א דרייסיק פראצענט איז געווען געמישטע, אפאר רוסן, אפאר גוים, אפאר פאלאקן. אזוי געמישט.
David Boder: איז דארטן געוועזן זונטיק פריי?
Joseph [last name unknown]: פריי איז געוועזן איינמאל אױף צוויי וואכן. זונטיק אדער שבת.
David Boder: [אומהערבאר]
Joseph [last name unknown]: אמאל איז אויסגעקימען אין שבת אמאל איז אויסגעקימען
David Boder: [אומהערבאר] דארטן פייער טעג.
Joseph [last name unknown]: זונטיק.
David Boder: וואס זאגט איר, האט מען אייך ערלויבט צו דאווענען דארטן? זענען געווען אזעלכע וועלכע האבן געוואלט דאווענען?
Joseph [last name unknown]: אין דעם ערשטן לאגער, אין דעם זיבעטן לאגער, האט מען אביסל געשטערט דאווענען.
David Boder: געשטערט?
Joseph [last name unknown]: געשטערט. יא. מען האט, זיי האבן אראפגעריסן די טליתים ביים דאווענען. אין אינעם צווייטן לאגער, האט מען אזוי, האט מען חוזק געמאכט.
David Boder: וואס הייסט עס?
Joseph [last name unknown]: מען האט געלאכט דארט פון דאווענען. אזוי אז דער עולם האט זיך געהיטן. מען האט איינעם אוועקגענומען די סידורל. מען איז אריינגעקימען מען האט אוועקגענומען די סידורים, מען האט אוועקגענומען די תפילין. עס האט זיך געטראפן, צווישן פינעף אין זעקס הונדערט יידן האט זיך נאך געטראפן א צוויי פאר תפילין. דאס, מען האט געדארפט, ווער עס האט נאך געקענט אדער עפעס.
David Boder: אבער א מנין האט מען נישט געמאכט?
Joseph [last name unknown]: ניין, מען האט נישט געטארט מאכן קיין מנין. א מנין האט מען אבסאלוט נישט געלאזט מאכן. עס האט געהייסן אז מען האט ארגאנאזירט.
David Boder: אינעם דריטן לאגער איז דאס געווען, אדער דאס איז געווען אין דעם צווייטן לאגער?
Joseph [last name unknown]: אינעם דריטן לאגער איז גענוי געווען אזוי, מיטן דאווענען, אז מען האט געדארפט דאווענען האט מען געדאווענט פאר זעך. שטילערהייט האט מען גארנישט געזאגט.
David Boder: וואס האבן געטאן די קריסטן, האבן זיי געהאט זייערע [אומהערבאר] דארטן, האבן זיי געהאט זייערע [אומהערבאר]?
Joseph [last name unknown]: געוועזן איז דארטן צוויי גלחים, האט מען זיי אוועקגעשיקט אין אן עקסטערע לאגער אריין. וועלכע לאגער, ווייס איך איבערהויפט נישט. זיי זענען נישט געווען נישט אין זיבעצן, נישט פופצן נישט ניינצן. אוועקגעשיקט אין א גאנץ בעזאנדערע לאגער.
David Boder: דארט זענט איר געווען ביז צום באפרייאונג. וואס פאר א באפרייאונג איז דאס געווען?
Joseph [last name unknown]: עס איז געקומען א באפעל אז פוילן האט געמאכט אן אפמאך מיט רוסלאנד און אז די אלע פוילישע בירגער ווערן באפרייט אויפן...אויפן...וועגן די אמנעסטי וואס איז ארויס זענען מיר אלע באפרייט געווארן אויף די
Joseph [last name unknown]: [In Polish] na podstawie. . . amnestia...
Joseph [last name unknown]: [In Yiddish] הייסט דאס.
David Boder: וואס הייסט?
Joseph [last name unknown]: [אומהערבאר] צוריק קײן פױלן.
David Boder: איר זענט דאך געווען פוילישע בירגער?
Joseph [last name unknown]: נו, אבער נישט קיין פוילנציגע?
David Boder: פארוואס, ווער דען?
Joseph [last name unknown]: מען האט באפרייט און מען איז געפארן זוכן איינער דעם צווייטן’ס קרובים. מען איז געפארן, געפארן, געפארן, מען איז אפגעקומען גאנצעטע חדשים מיטן פארן, מען איז קראנק געווארן, מען איז געשטארבן פאר פארן, [אומהערבאר] אויפן וועג.
David Boder: דאס הייסט מען האט אייך געלאזט פארן.
Joseph [last name unknown]: יא, מען האט געגעבן ביליעטן,
David Boder: בילעטן
Joseph [last name unknown]: מען האט געגעבן געלט.
David Boder: װאו זענט איר געפארן?
Joseph [last name unknown]: מען איז געפארן. דענמאלס האט זיך געגרינדעט די ארמיי, אנדערס ארמיי. סיקארסקי-אנדערס ארמײ דענמאלס האט זיך עס געגרינדעט. דען אלע יידן האבן געדינט אין די פוילישע ארמיי. די וואס האבן, מיינסטס זענען געפארן קיין בוזולוק, קײן [אומהערבאר], דארט האט זיך געמאכט די ארמיי. האט זיך געגרינדעט די ארמיי. דארטן ווען מען איז אהינגעקימען האט זיך אנגעהויבן א נייע גלות. א נייע פרישע גלות. דארט האט מען ערשט געשפירט אז מען איז א ייד.
David Boder: [אומהערבאר]
Joseph [last name unknown]: יא. דארטן האט מען אריינגעכאפט. אז מען האט געבעטן אביסל זופ, האט מען אריינגעכאפט א ביין אין קאפ אריין און מען האט באקימען א גוטן פאטש און מען האט אויף יעדן טריט און שריט האט מען סעקירט. עס איז נישט געווען צום אויסהאלטן. א סך יידן האבן געדינט אין די פוילישע ארמיי און זיי האבן נישט געקענט אויסהאלטן, זענען זיי ארויס פון די פוילישע ארמיי. און א סך ווידער האבן, זענען מיטגעפורן מיט די ארמיי קיין איראן.
David Boder: קיין וואו?
Joseph [last name unknown]: קיין איראן. אויף איראן זענען זיי געפורן.
David Boder: זאגט מיר, וואנען איז געוועזן ביי די רוסן דארט? האט מען געשלאגן?
Joseph [last name unknown]: ביי די רוסן, ניין, מען האט נישט געשלאגן, מען האט נישט אריינגעכאפט קלעפ.
David Boder: עס איז געוועזן שווער צו ארבעטן, אבער געשלאגן האט מען נישט.
Joseph [last name unknown]: ניין, געשלאגן האט מען נישט. נאר אז מען האט נישט געמאכט די נארמע וואס מען האט באדארפט מאכן. איז מען ממילא קראנק געווארן ווייל מען האט נישט געקענט באקומען דאס עסן. איז די מענטשן וואס האבן נישט געקענט אויסארבעטן די נארמע איז געווען איינער, איינער איז געווען אן אדוואקאט, איינער איז געווען א דאקטער, איינער איז געווען א, א, א קאן-טעכניק, האט ער געדארפט שניידן האלץ האט ער האט אבער נישט געקענט מאכן די נארמע,
David Boder: צו וואו זענט איר אוועקגעפארן דען?
Joseph [last name unknown]: מיר זענען געפארן קיין שרעדניא אזיען.
David Boder: איר זענט אריינגעגאנגן אין די ארמיי?
Joseph [last name unknown]: מיר זענען אריין אין די ארמיי אריין. די ארמיי האט זיך נישט געקענט אן עצה געבן ווייל זי האט נישט געהאט ווי צו, קיין פלאץ אזוי פיל. געגעבן צו עסן, האט מען אין די ארמיי גאנץ גיט, נאר א ייד האט מען זייער שטארק סעקירט. מען האט א ייד נישט געקענט אנקיקן, און יידן האבן געמוזט פון דארט אנטלויפן און אלעס האט געצויגן קיין שרעדניא אזיען. ווייל דארטן אין מיטל אזיאן איז ווארעם געוועזן און דארט איז שוין געווען זייער קאלט. עס איז אויסגעקימען, דענסטמאל איז אויסגעקומען אז מען איז שוין אריינגעקראכן אין ווינטער אריין, דארטן אין שרעדניא אזיען. אבער אין שרעדניא אזיען איז אויך געווען די זעלבע. דארט איז אויך געווען די ארמיי סיקארסקיס. דארט האט מען אויך געקענט גיין אין ארמיי אריין. איז פארגעקימען א סך פעלער וואס, אז מען איז אריין אין די ארמיי, און אינעם טוג וואס די ארמיי איז אוועק קיין איראן האט מען געהייסן יידן אויסטון די אוניפארם און זיי זענען געבליבן אין שרעדניא אזיען [אומהערבאר] אװעקגעפורן. און א סך זענען קראנק געווארן. איך בין קראנק געווארן אויף טיפוס. איך בין געלעגן זיבן וואכן אין שפיטול.
David Boder: וואס איז טיפוס? לעקסיפוס?
Joseph [last name unknown]: לעקסיפוס. יא.
David Boder: לייף.
Joseph [last name unknown]: לייף יא. יא לעקסיפוס. נאכדעם בין איך קראנק געווארן אויףדיזענטעריע, נאכדעם בין איך קראנק געווארן אויף פאנאס .איך בין אפגעליגן אין שפיטול פינעף חדשים.
David Boder: [אומהערבאר]
Joseph [last name unknown]: א דאנק וואס איז געווען א מיליטערישע גאספיטאל, אבער די רוסן האבן, די רוסישע, עס איז געווען רוסישע דאקטוירים, אין די פארפלעגונג איז געוועזן רוסישע, נאר עס איז געווען א גאספיטאל, א מיליטער שפיטאל [אומהערבאר] אין די ארמיי,סיקארסקיס ארמײ, מען האט אונז דארטן גאנץ גיט באהאנדלט, מען האט אונז זייער גיט געגעבן עסן, ווער עס האט אויסגעהאלטן, האט אויסגעהאלטן און מען איז ארויס.
David Boder: נא, ווען זענט איר ארויס?
Joseph [last name unknown]: איך בין ארויס פון שפיטאל און איך בין געגאנגן צי...דענסטמאל האט זיך געמאכט פלאצואװקעס. פוילישע פלאצואװקעס איז געווען. עס איז געווען א באשטיצונג, פין די אונגארישע באשטיצונג געווען, וואס מען האט אנגעהויבן צו געבן באשטיצונג.א יעדע פליכטלונג וואס איז געקימען האט אויפגעוויזן אז ער איז געווען אין לאגער, א פוילישע. מען האט אנגעהויבן צו באקימען באשטיצונג, דאס איז געווען א רוסישע לאגער, געוועזן אין א רוסישע לאגער. מען האט אויפגעוויזן
Joseph [last name unknown]: [In Russian] удостоверение.
Joseph [last name unknown]: [In Yiddish] [אומהערבאר]. מען איז באפרייט געווארן פון לאגער האט מען זיך רעגיסטרירט. אין יעדע שטאט איז געווען א פלאצופקע. מען האט באקימען זייף, מען האט באקימען געלט, מען האט באקימען אנצוטון, שיך, מען האט באקימען, מען האט געגעבן.
David Boder: [אומהערבאר]
Joseph [last name unknown]: יא .נאר אמבעסטנס האבן באקימען די וואס זענען געגאנגן צו די ארבעט. די וואס האבן נישט געארבעט, די האבן נישט געהאט קיין רעכט צו באקימען. אויסער אז זיי זענען געוועזן קראנק אין דאקטער האט זיי אויסגעהיילט. דענמאלטס האט מען נאר געקענט באקימען אויב מען האט געארבעט. איך דורכן טוג האב איך מיך געמוזט נעמען צו די ארבעט כאטש איך האב נישט געקענט, ווייל אז נישט, אן די ארבעט וואלט איך נישט געקענט אויסלעבן, נאר אדאנק וואס האב איך באקימען די אונטערשטיצונד פין די פלאצופקעס. קראנקערהייט האב איך געמוזט ארבעטן. איך האב אזוי געארבעט, ביז, נאך די ארבעט האב איך באקימען געשוואלענע פיס, עס איז געווען א דאקטער [אומהערבאר] װארשע.
David Boder: פון וואס זענען אייערע פיס געשוואלן געווארן? פון זייפן?
Joseph [last name unknown]: אונטן. ער האט מיר געזאגט אז עס פון הארץ אפגעשוואכט געווארן. פון הארץ, פון הארץ איז דאס שוואך געווארן. ער האט געזאגט אז איך טון נישט מער ארבעטן. ער האט מיך אוועקגעשיקט אין א דאם-אטדיך. דארט איז געווען א דאם-אטדיך אין גוסאר, שרעדניא אזיען, דארט איז געוועזן אויך א פלאצופקע. יידן. דארט האט מען נישט געארבעט. מען האט פארעכנט צו זיין דריי פיר וואכן אויף אויסרו. מען האט געגעבן גאנץ גיט צו עסן. דענמאלס איז ארויס א געזעץ. דאס איז געווען אין דריי און פערציגסטן יאר אים חודש מערץ איז ארויס א געזעץ אז אלע פוילישע מיזן נעמען פאשפארטן רוסישע, מאכן זיך פאר רוסישע בירגער, טאמער נישט האט מען א סך איינגעזעצט.
David Boder: [אומהערבאר]
Joseph [last name unknown]: יא. איך האב נישט געוואלט ווערן קיין סך איך האב שוין מורא געהאט, איך בין שוין געזעצן פערצן חדשים בין איך שוין געזעצן, האב איך גלייך גענומען א פאשפארט האב און אזוי ווי איך האב גענומען דעם פאשפארט האב איך איך
David Boder: אלץ רוסישער בירגער?
Joseph [last name unknown]: אלץ רוסישער בירגער, האב איך אנגעהויבן צו ארבעטן און איך האב געארבעט. עס איז נישט געווען שלעכט.
David Boder: גאנץ גוט צונוץ געקומען, [אומהערבער] פלאצואװקעס?
Joseph [last name unknown]: ניין, דענסטמאל זענען אלע פלאצואװקעס אויפגעלײזט געווארן. מען האט פארמאכט אלע פלאצואװקעס ליקווידירט. און עס עקזיסטירט נישט מער קיין פוילישע פלאצואװקעס. דענמאלס האט מען זיך געמוזט נעמען צי דער ארבעט, און מען האט זיך גענומען צי דער ארבעט. ווי איינער האט געהאט כח אויסצוהאלטן, נאר מען האט געמוזט נעמען פאשפארטן. אן א פאשפארט האט מען נישט געקענט עקזיסטירן. אזוי ווי מען האט גענומען די פאש’פארטן, האט מען גענומען און מען האט פארשיקט פארשידענס אויפ די פראנט האט מען אוועקגעשיקט מענטשן.
David Boder: וואס איז דאס געוועזן?
Joseph [last name unknown]: דאס הייסט. א [אומהערבער] פראנט דאס ווערט אנגערופן אן ארבייטער, א מאביליזירונג פין...
David Boder: [אומהערבער] מען גיט זיי צו ארבעטן. איר האט געארבעט?
Joseph [last name unknown]: [אומהערבער] פארשידענס. מיר האט מען געשיקט אויף [אומהערבאר]
David Boder: נישט צום פראנט [אומהערבאר]
Joseph [last name unknown]: [In Yiddish]ניין [אומהערבאר]. דאס איז אלעס [אומהערבאר]. אזוי אז מען האט, א יעדער איינער האט זיך גענומען פאשפארטן. מען האט זיך גענומען צו די ארבעט. מען האט שוין געהאט א רעכט צו וואוינען אין שטוט. מען האט שוין פארבעסערט אלעס. דארט זענען מיר געוועזן דריי און פערציג, פיר און פערציג, פינף און פערציג ביז דער קריג’ס צום ענדע. דער קריג איז צום ענדע, האט מען ווידער געהערט נייעס אז מען פורט קיין פוילן.
David Boder: מיט די רוסישע פאשפארט?
Joseph [last name unknown]: אז די רוסישע פאשפארטן ווערן איבערגענומען. זיי געבן ארויס א דאקומענט, א האלב א פוילישן, א האלב א רוסישן. אין ביי די גרעניץ – מיר זענען אהיימגעפןרן קיין פוילן – ביי די גרעניץ האט מען אפגענומען די רוסישע דאקומעט מיטן פאשפארט, מען האט אלעס אוועקגענומען, געבליבן איז נאר א שטיקעלע דאקומענט אויף פויליש געשריבן. מיר זענען אהיימגעפורן קיין פוילן מיטן טראנספארט און מיר זענען צוריק געקימען קיין פוילן אין מאנאט יול.
David Boder: זעקס און פערציג?
Joseph [last name unknown]: זעקס און פערציג.
David Boder: אזוי שפעט?
Joseph [last name unknown]: יא, יא. די לעצטע טראנספארט.
David Boder: יול 46?
Joseph [last name unknown]: יא. יא.
David Boder: דאס איז פיר וואכן צוריק.
Joseph [last name unknown]: פיר וואכן צוריק. יא. יא.
David Boder: היינט האבן מיר [אומהערבער] סעפטעמבער
Joseph [last name unknown]: סעפטעמבער. נו...
David Boder: צוויי מאנאטע.
Joseph [last name unknown]: צוויי מאנאטע. מיר זענען געקומען קיין פוילן, האבן מיר געמיינט אז מיר וועלן קענען עקזיסטירן אינ דער היים. עס איז דאך אונזער היים פוילן. מיר האבן דארט געלעבט אזוי פיל יאר, די טאטעס מיט די זיידעס. האט מען מיר געזוגט אז מען טון נישט ארויסגיין אין די גאס אריין,
David Boder: ווער האט דאס געזאגט? די אנדערע יידן?
Joseph [last name unknown]: די יידן וואס זענען ארויסגעקימען צו די באן, צו די באן זענען ארויסגעקימען יידן און זיי האבן געזוגט מען זאל זיך נישט דרייען אין די גאסן, ווייל היינט האט מען געשאסן – עס איז אדורכגעפורן א צוג ביינאכט וואס איז געגאנגן ווארשע, לובלין האט מען ארויסגענומען ביינאכט פיר יידן, מען ווייסט וואס איז געשען – צומארגענס איז מען געווארן אז מען האט זיי געשאסן. און [אומהערבאר]
David Boder: [In English] This concludes Spool 158 with the report of a Mr. Joseph, and we will continue Spool 159. Illinois Institute of Technology wire recording. Wiesbaden, September the 26th, 19—...eh, 25th, September the 25th, 1946. Illinois Institute of Technology wire recording.